mark your calendars because today's the
day when the cbs hit show the talk
returns this afternoon there will be two
new faces at the table
starting this afternoon amanda kloots
love her and elaine welterroth love her
too
we'll co-host a daytime emmy
award-winning show with sharon
osbourne carriana naba and sheryl
underwood
clues as you know is a former broadway
dancer and radio city rockette turned
celebrity trainer and business owner
elaine welteroff is a badass the new
york times best-selling author
award-winning journalist
former editor-in-chief of teen vogue and
a judge on project runway they're both
very very busy girls so we really
appreciate you guys
taking the time congratulations to you
both does it sort of feel like
the first day of school elaine you go
first
totally it 100 feels like the first day
of school
and um except we're going to see gayle
king
on on zoom from your living room so it's
going to be there very
very simple but um i picked out an
outfit that i hope you like
oh yeah it's not about you i know isn't
it something i know we spend so much
time picking out the first day outfit
amanda
how are you feeling you know we are
always cheering you on i want to know
how both of you got the news and your
reaction
but amanda you start how are you feeling
today
i am feeling so great i barely slept
because i also had those
day of school jitters um but i'm so
excited for today i think it's going to
be so much fun and i think the five
of us are really going to bring a unique
perspective
to the talk yeah elaine listen you've
you've set in a couple of times so you
know exactly how it works
but i hear there's a funny thing when
you told your mom the news i like this
story
that you got the job because you're a
newlywed we should say
you got you got married in may first
we'll show we'll show it we'll show it
first and then you can explain
but you got married in may so you're a
newlywed congrats
yes wait we're going to play the sound
you have
yeah what do you think
no nothing
i got the
[Music]
as a mom who's hoping for a pregnancy
one day
i can't imagine that your mom was a
little disappointed when she heard you
weren't with baby yet
but she had to be very excited that you
got this job because this is
you're going to be great at this elaine
what'd she say
thank you so much no i it's the funniest
part of that video
now hearing it back is hearing jonathan
in the background going
no no no no because it was like he was
watching this train wreck happen
slowly um but my mom was my first call
she's like my best friend
and i'm sure she's watching right now
and squealing that that video was just
shown
um but she was she definitely thought i
was
announcing my pregnancy which is not
that
it's not happening um but she was so
excited to find out that
um that i got this incredible
opportunity and
you know she was watching during the
times that i guess hosted she's a huge
fan of the show
she loves all the ladies and she was
thrilled when she found out that
not only that i got the job but that
amanda got the job she was a big fan of
amanda's as well so
yeah my whole family is super super
excited about this new new chapter
we all fell in love with amanda because
amanda's you know we all followed your
journey you lost your beloved nick to
covet
19 during this year so 2020 was not a
good year and then it ends on this note
for you we're very very excited about
that but you talked about
how your new co-host have helped you i'm
wondering how you're coping because in
july i remember we had talked to you but
still
i have to say hard for me to believe i
wonder how you're doing
you know every day is a a different day
gail
it's uh the journey of grief is
something that i'm learning a lot about
and i'm just taking one day at a time
and on hard days
i just try to get through those days and
on happy days i try to celebrate them
and um you know one day at a time that's
that's how i'm i'm looking at it but
i'm so excited to start this job start
this journey
and um have a new family to go to every
morning i
i feel honestly i feel so lucky and i
feel so lucky to
be working alongside elaine now too i
love her
and i i just i can't wait to go to work
every morning yeah you do
that's i love what what you said amanda
because you do have a new family
you have so many people who are willing
you on cheering for you and can't wait
to see you all
sitting at the table what are you all
most looking forward to because you know
the secret of the talk is people come
and they sort of
share their own life experiences they
expose themselves
warts and all are either of you worried
about that
don't get amanda go ahead amanda i'm not
i think
um it's wonderful to live a very honest
life and to share those things that make
us imperfect because
everyone has those imperfections and
it's what makes us stronger people
so i'm excited to show those and those
cracks and then fill those cracks with
things that we learn from the other
ladies and things that we learn from our
audience
yeah the audience is key elaine
yeah no absolutely i think amanda said
it really well
i i think especially for women i think
there's something really powerful
happens when women
give themselves permission to tell their
truth
you know i think it gives other women
permission to tell
their truth too so for me every every
morning when you come
together with these women especially
during covid you know
they're quarantined without having this
live studio audience it really feels
like this
intimate safe space with
familiar faces warm women who create
this really
comfortable environment to share to be
honest
and there's this sense that everyone's
perspectives
are valued respected we're here to learn
from each other to support each other
and i think in a moment like this it's a
really it's a really
important thing to see modeled um on
television especially at a time when a
lot of us
don't have those close physical
connections that we're so used to and we
aren't able to see our girlfriends and
our family members so i feel like we're
able to create that
connection hopefully with the audience
but we certainly feel that together
on set even even in the short time that
i've that i've had the opportunity to be
on the show
so i feel really comfortable sharing
i've already embarrassed myself i've
already put some of my secrets out there
um uh somehow they got me to share that
i
fell asleep during black panther which
is
insane and um with my friends
so um no i think we're gonna go we're
gonna be ourselves we're gonna be
transparent be authentic and i think
that's what we're excited
we're all excited to do that is the
secret sauce that makes it fun guys i'm
so happy for you both listen
2020 was such a crappy year for so many
on so many levels and so many reasons
but there were some bright spots
so i'm thinking i'm very optimistic
about 2021 even though we have a lot of
the same issues
starting off with you guys i think is a
really great great note for all of us so
congrats
and i'll see you this afternoon i'll see
you this afternoon
hey what to wear what to wear i'll see
you a little bit later on
amanda cloots and elaine welterroth
cheering you on always and you can watch
them on the talk weekday starting today
at two o'clock eastern one central and
pacific right here on
cbs